vladimir putin and xi jinping standing
shoulder to shoulder sharing what they
describe as an unshakable bond
the leaders of russia and china met
ahead of the opening of the winter
olympics in beijing
it's the first time president xi has met
a foreign counterpart in person since
the beginning of the pandemic
our spirit of friendship and the
strategic partnership have reached the
unprecedented level
at the sochi window olympics 80 years
ago we promised to meet again we have
kept that promise
the leaders signed a joint statement
presenting a united front on a range of
foreign policy issues
they called for nato to end its
expansion
and for the military alliance to abandon
its so-called cold war approach
they also denounced the orca security
alliance between the united states
britain and australia
and the formation of further blocks in
the asia pacific
the statement comes as both russia and
china experience souring ties with the
u.s and its western and european allies
but those allies are also at odds
they see that the west is not speaking
with one voice and and has some uh
division so this benefits both russia
and china
the visit comes as tensions escalate
over the presence of more than one
hundred thousand russian soldiers on its
border with ukraine
washington is threatening to impose
tough sanctions on moscow should its
forces invade
beijing says russia's security concerns
are legitimate the intention
here is to send a very clear message uh
to the west that russia has options that
russia china relationship is a possible
alternative for for moscow that it is
not going to be backed into a corner
the leaders are expected to sign 15
agreements on issues ranging from trade
to technology during putin's visit
russia will increase gas supplies to
china and has announced a 30-year
contract for a new pipeline between the
two nations china already receives gas
through what's named the power of
siberia pipeline that began pumping
supplies in 2019.
economic support from china could
undermine any western effort to punish
any possible russian incursion into
ukraine but analysts say an even bigger
concern is a possible deepening of
military cooperation between moscow and
beijing
xi jinping has often spoken of his deep
friendship with vladimir putin who was
the first major leader to confirm his
attendance at the beijing winter
olympics
the us uk canada and australia have not
sent officials to the event in protest
against china's human rights record
katrina u al jazeera beijing